you can't tell I am so excited to be
here I can tell you're on the theme
right yeah I like him how did you settle
on a look like this for tonight oh well
I'm hugely Lucky in that I have some old
friends that work at Balenciaga okay and
I'm wearing a really magnificent
Balenciaga Couture piece this evening
that was created for me
um by the amazing demna and his
incredible team in Paris and um I'm just
over the moon you know I wanted to work
with Tim Burton my entire life and I
wanted to feel like a Tim Burton
illustration brought to life so it felt
like this was well it was gonna be I
mean you're honestly a work of art truly
truly truly let's talk about more about
the transformation in this show though
what was it like to step into this world
and transform into this character I
truly loved working on the show
Wednesday is certainly a unique name
I'm guessing it was the day of the week
you were born I was born on Friday the
13th it was amazing to play a character
the likes of which I've never played
before to look so entirely different to
actually have a go at looking more
conventionally feminine than I ever have
done before and I suppose it should be
no surprise that Tim Burton sees me in a
totally different way than anyone else
does and he made me feel beautiful and
he made me feel very liberated and gave
me a huge amount of confidence and it
was a great opportunity to play and I
just had the most magnificent time and
got to work with people like Colleen
Atwood who's a total genius and made the
most stupendous costumes Danny elfman's
doing the music Jenna Ortega's playing
Wednesday Christina Ricci it's a
Catherines it was an amazing course and
Louise Guzman working with him was uh
something I never thought would happen
he's a legend and uh and a truly great
actor you've been geeking out like me
all night that has literally all these
amazing people real quick have you been
watching house with a dragon like the
rest of us I I have notices oh no I have
not I was very lucky in that Game of
Thrones was such a huge part of my life
for the best part of a decade and um
what's wonderful now is being able to
embrace new things and I wish them all
the best
[Music]